[Music]
this took one hour to make how did you
get to where you are right now
what is this called damage do you ever
get beat down i don't think if
they were very enthused for their son to
be a dj
you gotta do what you like to do and
work yourself doing the
foreigners think i'm american the
americans think i'm bored this is yours
i really feel it
[Music]
got a video i'm super excited about
today guys we're meeting up with
danny asadi he's a musician here in los
angeles
known around the world for his persian
trap music
now most views that most musicians fail
when they come to this city
he's not he's making it let's get into
his story today
hear how he's making it also get into
his background and learn more about his
style
of music
so i came into danny's music when i did
a video series about iran
and i was looking for the fusion music
right of like what's that iranian
feel but what's something that a western
audience would
dig yeah because the traditional iranian
stuff while it's good
you know i think it would put off most
of the western audience
and then if i didn't have any iranian
influence it wouldn't have felt iranian
exactly and that's when that's when dany
assadi came into the mix
and unfortunately for you it was my
first
youtube video series and i had no idea
what i was doing
so i was asking around about music
and the iranian people i was talking and
said yeah just put it in there just put
it in there it'll be fine
i'm like what about copyright i heard of
this copyright thing and they're like
yeah no problem they're like the right
to copy
yeah the right to copy it's your right
and then
i put the music in the series and i got
the copyright strike but
thank god danny gets the money for it
but i apologize wait i was gonna show
you this oh yeah this is uh
one of my favorite ice cream places
actually my favorite ice cream place
there's there's like rose white rose
jasmine like lavender
orange blossom it's an iranian iranian
business persian ice cream yeah it
started in iran 75 years ago
wow for about 40 years
i can only go to iran once a year and i
can only stay there for
not more than three months before that i
gotta head out
because if you stay more than three
months then you kind of got to join the
army yeah
you got the you got the scarf for it but
that's about it right you don't want to
jump in
the other stuff for him you know this
isn't going to protect me from anything
so a question i have and i'm sure a lot
of you guys have if you're into music i
want to know how to
people succeed in music in los angeles
it's like
how did you get here and how did you how
did you get to where you are right now
because it seems like this last year
maybe you're especially taking off
honestly this year has been so far
like the best my career has ever been
because i feel like
i feel like i finally figured out what i
want
when i am what do you want i want to do
what i want to do
for once without worrying about
whether it's something that will make me
go viral or not
okay so you're just staying completely
true to your
your creative mindset and what you want
to do so i make like
persian uh persian influence electronic
music
okay where i play a lot of i play like
traditional persian music
i use traditional persian music online i
collaborate with
traditional persian musicians and
artists to create
to influence electronic music in america
and also hip-hop music in america and
thus hopefully internationally
and i for the you know for the longest
time i would call this
persian trap music because it was i was
really into the trap
right sound right and um and for those
that don't know the trap sound is that
you know the fingers on the what is that
what is that instrument called
and i'm not a musician as you can tell
that's just a drum pad
trump hat okay but um no it's not a
that has nothing to do with the genre of
trap okay um
like i know this is what the sound of
trap is but what distinguishes
um trap specifically um it derived from
like the tr808 which is like a machine
from roland that created the 808 sound
like the point
in like hip-hop music like that's a trap
okay like when you have that boom or
when you have um
like that like the analog hi-hats like
if
these all derive from like this one
machine that people started using
for a style of hip-hop that was
eventually called trap music
because interesting because it was like
it was like famous in like trap houses
in atlanta
okay like that style that the style that
they came up with
right derived from these sounds came
from the trap houses in atlanta where
they were smuggling drugs selling drugs
yeah so that's why it was called trap
music because they're trapping
well i was always inspired by the edm
side when i was younger
and i wanted to always incorporate make
my own version of it
where it was middle eastern influence
and i've been pursuing that since i was
like
14 15 years old your parents are from
iran but you grew up here
yes i grew up in columbus ohio but you
feel a connection
with the motherland with iran yeah
absolutely
never fully though never fully
in between the two or like the
in-betweener yeah okay
i'm like a direct definition of an
in-betweener like the
foreigners think i'm american the
american the americans think i'm bored
you know and your music is exactly in
the middle too
i would say i hope so i that you know
that was done on purpose i want to i
want the whole world for once
to hear middle eastern music and in my
case particularly persian music and be
like
oh i love persian music right right this
song and it's
a saudi like that's that's what i want
you know the way i would try to market
my music is i would do these videos
so i would make these like 60 second
videos that were like
i tried to make as engaging as possible
on my instagram
and just kept knocking it out right and
it kind of reached a point where
i was getting known for my videos and
being less known for my music my actual
music i was like really passionate about
that i put so much time and effort in
and you know sure
like my precious little babies that i
put out on spotify i want the world to
see
right and um totally my fault because i
got so carried away with the video
because i was doing so well
and i was getting such a good following
this year is the year where i'm finally
like
just like screw it i just i want to do
what i
absolutely love to do and just show that
to the world and i'll still do the
videos and stuff
but i wanna just it's gonna take longer
and it's gonna
it's not gonna get as much engagement
but it's what i love to do and now when
i
when i get half as many views for a
video that
is more and as like a well-produced
music video that's not intended to be
some
quick little tick tock right right if i
get half as many views as like the tick
tocky videos that i made like
i get so excited because like this is
working like people are
accepting this and the algorithms that
we see online the insights that you see
online
that show how many views you got will
never show how many fans you got
how many people that are emotionally
attached to your music
when there was no social media the only
thing that would show
would give you a good sign that you're
like actually making a name for yourself
is sales for your actual song
and people recognizing you in the street
right you know and that's what they've
been doing
very little time here so the music
puts me in a trance it puts me in a like
a meditative
surrealistic sort of space where i lose
a bit of time
if i'm in the right moment like if i'm
in the right mood i can listen to one of
your songs and get like out there for a
bit
which i love it's the same as looking at
a really like a surrealist
uh piece of art like a dolly or a
margarite or something
it brings me out into this other state
this other state of mind
almost like a psychedelic without taking
a psychedelic yeah
so would you say because there are a lot
of musicians that want to come up
and bring their art to the world yeah
what would be a couple tips and you
already gave one it was stay
like where you're at now you have enough
of an audience but staying true to what
you want to do
yeah and i i do agree with that too
because my videos are all over the place
yeah i was with a diamond merchant the
other day yeah i was in the hood in
watts
two days ago yeah like i'm going into
every different space and while that
might not be great for audience because
it's
you know if you just stick to one genre
completely you can probably
build more of a core fan but i just do
what i like because i don't want to get
bored of it
you know so you're a great example you
do what you like
yeah but you work your ass off doing it
yeah that's all you got to do
yeah that's all you gotta do is yeah you
gotta do what you like to do
and work your ass off doing it my
mindset now is less about
doing um quick gimmicky publicity yep
to like just harvest a bunch of
followers
that don't really care about me that
much right
and more like building one after another
a quality
super fan and eventually at this rate
eventually i have built such a strong
foundation that
it would heart it would be hard to fall
off as an artist
be very hard to
this is caspian right here yeah
this took one hour to make right but
really it was
probably years of practicing and
experimenting and thinking and
correct and then it just like one day
spilled out of you yeah
where are we going now let's get some
food is it going to be the greatest
persian armenian restaurant in los
angeles save los angeles this is the
persian palace
[Music]
glendale california rafi's place
so who is this this guy's name is
fatimatis aslani
and he's like a legend like everyone
knows who he is
it's like almost the equivalent of
playing with johnny cash or something
yeah like the person johnny cash bob
dylan
do you use some of that type of music in
your music absolutely
like literally like my music now
like what i create now
it's so traditional like so conservative
but with this foundation of like modern
um arrangement
yeah you know the the
the drums the electronic drums that i
involved the texture
the sound effects and stuff
thank you ever since i was a kid i
always had this mindset of like
like i need to work hard now
and i'm like 12 years old so i can blow
up when i'm like
18. and then uh
then i'm like 14 and i'm like
i don't think i'm going to blow up when
i'm 18. i'm i'm i'm not even close to
there yet right
so then i'm 14 and i'm like oh i know
what i'm doing wrong i need to be doing
this
and i'm like working even harder right
right always so competitive myself
to be like as successful as possible as
young as possible but it never
it only discouraged me once when i
turned 18
and i was like i'm not big yet like i'm
not i didn't reach my goal right
and i said that to someone and someone
like straight up laughed at me like dude
you're 18 years old
and then when i realized i was like okay
maybe
it's okay if you reach a goal and you
don't hit it because when you shoot for
the stars and you reach the moon at
least you still reach the moon
now you're 25. now i'm 25. yeah this is
you feel this is your year
i really feel it i really feel it
you feel it just be by being near danny
it's coming over the table
it's an energy it's an energy i feel in
your music
and i feel it being around you and you
never had to do like uh the l.a
do do music and also work a restaurant
job at the same time i've been blessed
i didn't i didn't ever have to do that
no i was 14 and
and my dad came home from iran he
brought a sitar
and when he brought this thing to the
center uh it kind of looks like
like a almost it's a loot so it kind of
looks like a
like a wooden spoon with strings on it
um and this is the persian sitar this is
in the
indian sitar it's it's a it's a
completely different instrument and when
my dad brought it home from iran
uh he he visited iran he brought home i
was just blown away
like from then on i was like because i
didn't know about this kind of stuff
that there was like
that us persons had our own instruments
like i thought that was so
cool i thought that was so unique and
when i went to iran with my dad like the
following year
and saw all these persian music stores
the walls of satar's and all these other
instruments that i've never seen before
in my life i just wanted to buy all of
it i wanted all of it
and at the same time i learned about
electronic music like electronics was
first becoming a thing
um and i also learned about the
technology side of music and like how
you can play like
orchestras on your keyboard and arrange
it on on a software on your computer
yeah and i found out that that was
called
producing oh fantastic awesome
thank you thank you so much
what is this called danny
okay so traditional iranian yeah and i
love that how they do the uh the charred
vegetables yeah has that been your
your uh guiding principle you try just
try try
try try always try it always
do you ever get beat down yes with a big
smile on my face
you know but what about outside voices
does that ever affect you or not
i'm sure you get mostly positive outside
voices always affect people
yeah um everyone everyone sometimes
at the very least sometimes gets
affected by outside voices so i'm not
gonna try to say like i don't listen to
anyone like
no that's not but um
i like to think that i trust my
god before i listen to any anything
anyone else that tells right
right very good
um persians love their rice
yeah light light fluffy rice
yeah it's comfort food yeah it's like
pasta for italians
exactly you know my parents
left iran moved to you know the united
states
are u.s citizens trying to live the
american dream
right and i don't think they were very
enthused
for their son to be like a dj
or some [ __ ] you know but then they
started to realize man this kid
is either gonna he's gonna be he's gonna
die being a musician
like you can't change that about it when
did they figure that out when i was like
18
and they're like okay uh it was when i
was it was when i was 18 and i dropped
out of
college and uh they said just go to just
go to college for music
and uh they really helped me out like
they helped me move all the way down to
florida
where i went to university there in
orlando for music
got me an apartment like just continued
spoiling the [ __ ] out of me
and then when i was ready to move to la
they were like oh great we want to come
to l.a too
no way they moved because you moved big
move because i moved
and they always wanted a reason to leave
ohio where i grew up because they're
just sick of it they just wanted to live
somewhere nice
all right guys a little insight to a
musician that's
made it here and around the world
cross-cultural fusion of music yes sir
of cultural identity and uh
wow you guys got to listen to what he
has to offer danny assadi
it's been awesome man it's it's a
pleasure it's a pleasure to be on your
channel this seriously this is
you're really cool you're a cool man
thank you i'm very grateful to be around
you let alone
be in your videos appreciate it yeah
yeah and i had danny's music and my
iranian videos i'll leave those
down below too definitely watch them
those videos are so cool you guys gotta
watch that
all right cool all right man thanks so
much until the next one guys
next week take care i think that you can
just
do something because you love to do it
don't do it because it's getting you
clout only do it because you love to do
it
yeah but do it consistently and work
your
ass off doing it i think you're going to
end up being where you want to be
[Music]